all right let's go to five headlines
[Music]
number one kanye west appears to
actually be running for president
it seems i i admit that that comes as a
bit of surprise to me i assume that this
was all a stunt to sell albums
which i'm still not convinced it isn't i
think i think maybe that is what this is
but
he did hold an actual campaign rally of
sorts this weekend
and he's got petitions to get him on the
ballots in various states
um i don't know what the end game is
maybe the end game is 1600 pennsylvania
avenue
who knows the kanye doubters like myself
it's as if we've already forgotten that
a reality tv
game show host won the presidency in
2016
despite how improbable that seemed at
the time to people like me
in any case the highlight of kanye's
event without question
i think was his very emotional and
compelling
discussion about abortion and he reveals
um some things that i that was new to me
i'd never heard this before i'm not sure
if you talked about it publicly in the
past or not
but he reveals why the issue is so
important to him and why he takes it so
personally watch this
i'm pregnant i say yes
it's not going to tell you what was in
my mind she was crying
she said i just came here to talk to her
because i was having my you know the
rapper's lifestyle
so she said she was pregnant
and for one month and two months and
three months
we talked about her not having this
child
she had the pills in her hand and people
know the skills
where you take the pills and if you take
it it's a wrap the baby's gone
my mom saved my life my dad wanted to
abort me
my mom saved my life there would have
been no kanye west
because my dad was too busy
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
now kanye has obviously sustained a lot
of criticism recently
when he put out the christian album and
he came you know was coming out in
support of donald trump even though i
guess he's backtracked from that
recently and said he doesn't support
trump anymore but all of that criticism
is was nothing in comparison to what's
coming to kanye now
because once you start talking about
abortion and especially talk about the
way that he is
that's a powerful testimony not only as
a man who as he says almost
you know almost was never born and his
life was saved by his mother but
he's admitting that he himself um
if it were up to him would have aborted
his child
and his wife stepped in and said no
we're not going to do that now he's he's
looking at his daughter and is
obviously grateful every day that he
didn't make such a horrible choice
that is that's a very powerful testimony
um to hear from someone
a man a black man you know
and the left cannot tolerate that they
they simply they can't have someone
going around saying this kind of
thing about abortion their holy
sacrament
so just watch if you thought it was bad
before
you're gonna see the treatment now that
kanye gets and it's gonna be
it already has been uh ugly
number two as we get close to i guess
our third straight month of leftist
violence and chaos
there are no signs of it letting up uh
here are just
some examples over the weekend here are
leftists in seattle breaking into
an amazon store to steal stuff
and then we go over to portland there's
rioting in portland featuring the
familiar
serial arson um and here are some antifa
terrorists trying to start fires
in in the city
and it's not just portland and seattle
either let's be clear about that 18
officers
were injured while protecting a
christopher columbus statue
from being torn down in chicago um
and you could see how they were injured
here are the quote-unquote protesters
throwing rocks and bottles and other
assorted
projectiles at the officers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
remember two things though folks number
one first of all
all the people you've seen in those
videos those are poor starving children
who just want some bread
according to aoc they just want bread
that's all
why won't someone give them some bread
that's all they're looking for they're
going into an amazon store looking for
bread i don't think they're gonna find
any there
but that's it these are starving people
who desperately are
they're just committing crime out of
desperation because
they're on the brink of starvation and
they figure the only way to survive
is to throw bottles at police officers
makes a lot of sense
and second um also remember that
even in spite of everything you've seen
there and everything we've seen over the
last two or three months
we should really be worried about the
real problem the real threat
is that federal law enforcement officers
in scary camo uniforms are
quote unquote abducting people off the
street otherwise known as making arrests
because after that one video that we
played last week of
some police officers in uniform saying
police
went and uh and quote-unquote kidnapped
someone and put him in an
unmarked van and we're supposed to see
this as some horrible new
innovation by the police no unmarked
vehicles are very common police have
been using them for a very long time
um and kidnapping someone off the street
otherwise known as
making an arrest that's that's what an
arrest is
are we now saying that arrests have to
be consensual is it
is this a no means no situation where
the person could say no officer uh i
prefer not to be arrested today
in fact maybe maybe try back tomorrow
but i'm just not in the mood for her for
an arrest
oh okay if you don't want to be arrested
then never mind have a great day
and we laugh about it but that is that
is really actually what the left wants
that's that's
basically their vision of how policing
should work
number three reading from the daily wire
uh
it says a pair of doctors in australia
want to do away with terms like adam's
apple
and achilles tendon with one doctor
calling them misogynistic
dr kristen small a queensland specialist
obstetrician gynecologist anatomy
lecturer
calls for the terms to be phased out
saying that they represent older
generations
i think we have personal choice to
decolonize our language and these
historical terms will fade out
says small she still teaches the terms
known as
eponyms for exam purposes but notes that
there are alternatives for the dead
man's names
she says the century-old anatomical
terms are named after old men
kings and heroes uh and i guess we gotta
get rid of adam's apple because
it's believed to be named after the
biblical figure of adam
okay of course achilles tendon named
after the greek hero of the trojan war
i don't know why that's sexist exactly
but apparently it is
we have to get rid of that you know this
is another thing that we kind of laugh
about because it's so silly and it is
silly
but there is we always have to remember
with these pc name changes
there's something nefarious under the
surface of this and because it's all
about control it's about controlling
what we say how we speak
controlling the language it's something
the left has been doing for a long time
and they've been very successful
it's been one of their most successful
ploys and tactics
let's go to number four well we call
this
this segment five headlines so here is
the headline
claremont 13 year old dies after
experiencing covid19
symptoms this is the headline from
los angeles the cbs affiliate in los
angeles
uh that's that's it claremont 13 year
old dies after experiencing coven 19
symptoms
and other outlets like the daily mail
have picked this up and had
almost exactly the same headline now
you read that you think that's that's
obviously horrible
um and you you read through it now i
read the article
it's not until you get to let's see one
two three four
five you have to get six paragraphs in
before you get to this on july ninth uh
mac
the boy's mother took him to get tested
for cover 19
that test came back negative
the mother says his symptoms matched but
then the test came out negative so we
were a little bit confused okay so
what we have here put in the headline
dies after experiencing cover 19
symptoms
uh don't tell us until six paragraphs in
he tested negative for the virus
so what so all we have from this story
all we know
is that this was a child he had coveted
symptoms
which means what fever coughing that
sort of thing
and then he died so what we know for
sure is that it's a terrible tragedy
but that's all we know for sure
and we also know he tested negative for
covert 19. now
uh that doesn't mean he didn't have it
you could get a false negative
that does happen but there's no reason
at all to assume he had a false negative
in fact based on the reporting there's
no reason to assume that his symptoms
had anything to do with his death we
don't know
they said they're going to do an autopsy
we don't have the results of that yet
so what we have the media doing here is
blatantly explicitly
exploiting the death of a 13 year old
child
for their own purposes for clicks and
ratings and for political reasons too
because they want to scare people they
desperately want to scare people
especially when it comes to there's no
coincidence here
that they're taking this headline and
they they're they're they're reporting
in a in an extremely let's call it
misleading way
right when we're in the middle of
debating you know opening schools or not
and trump obviously is out in favor of
opening them up
the media they're looking for and they
want to find
stories of kids dying of covet 19. and
if they can't find it then they're going
to do this
which is grotesque and disgusting and
evil and they know exactly what they're
doing
by the way covid symptoms
those are also flu symptoms and since we
know that flu
kills three times as many kids in his
age bracket
why not assume that it was the flu if
we're gonna make any assumptions at all
you just as easily assume that he died
of the flu or here's a better
case here's a better idea don't make any
assumptions
make zero assumptions wait for the
autopsy to come back and then
you know wait wait for actual
information about what killed this child
number five um i have no idea of the
context here but i've seen some people
talking about this on social media
uh i guess in new york people are
getting this alert on their phone here
it is
there's one one person on twitter uh has
a screenshot says
report of man armed with banjo
there's a man armed with a banjo
somewhere i guess the police are
responding i don't know what's happening
the
details are very sketchy what i want to
say first of all is that the attempts
that have been made to connect me
to this incident are baseless and
libelous
i was not involved in this event i have
no knowledge of it
second though i was not involved let me
say
that i understand why this happened
whatever happened i understand why it
happened we banjo players we members of
the banjo community we
banjo-ists as we call ourselves
have been minimized and otherized and
stigmatized
and marginalized and dehumanized
and vaporized and
cauterized all the eyes we we
for too long that's happened to us
there's only so much you can take after
a while
i mean when you hear banjo okay
the word banjo you you hear the the
sound of a banjo the glorious
beautiful sound what's the first movie
you think of
with the banjo right you think of
deliverance this is how my community
has been portrayed on film for decades
hillbilly
backwoods rapists so
is it any wonder that a community which
has been the target of such
degrading stereotypes and prejudices
would would lash out in this way in
whatever way this was
whatever happened can you can you blame
us for communicating our anger and our
sorrow
in a way that gets your attention
i'm not justifying it whatever happened
just saying a little bit of empathy i
think would be
necessary well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt walsh show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content